there's something to target for one
thing and it's in the back of the store
it's actually pretty long walk got to
get those notes candy hearts aren't even
Star Wars theme that one says fling you
know exactly what you'd expect the
stormtrooper to say other no peeps I was
expecting peek a little real pard
good morning John good morning John it's
time to get ill red velvet warrior now
we're going to start why muscle oreos up
like it's the perfect cookie what I'm
here for the cream cheese icing I could
eat these all right well then you will
calm I got very bitter this is a Reese's
Pieces with the legal part oh they're
just something I am wild about that
that's going to end up in the background
to Hanks videos or that good chance you
don't want to review those for later
oh yeah they really know what they're
doing with these hi I'm Travis Rochelle
it made in Belgium oh that's been China
Wow
oh it's father fell right off I'm going
to like hold it out in your mouth and
blow this out hey let's take a bite out
of it together like we're waiting in the
tram no I'm sorry in Georgia try one of
these I hate strawberry and chocolate
honestly maybe you'll be surprised I was
surprised by the red velvet Oreos to in
here oh my God look like a pop tart but
with chocolate I like strawberry
pop-tart he's good Terry yeah we're
gonna pop sorry Charlie okay so this is
the quintessential Valentine
conversation heart the quality control
is going right out the window
yeah like Cassidy's don't even have
anything on them I've not been knowing a
candy to make note of this nerd rope
we made different noises the same noise
Lady and the God come on baby
nerds have another nerd amongst cotton
candy should only happen in one place
and I feel weird having purchased it in
the store I like it though it's good
yeah release our heart is our little
troublingly sticky oh I like that was my
favorite sugar baked candy so far
chocolate truffle kisses like Hershey's
kisses like they were made this shape
because they were just drops of
chocolate but now this has been
manufactured to be this shape yeah so
they can put something inside of it
cruel piece yeah I got professor poop in
the bathroom what did he do it with
gathering oil paper enjoyment David
Harden is better than a regular kiss yes
really and we're going to finish off
with a liqueur made funded Valentine
mystery flavors I have to logistic
lovely a candy it's like feared giant
till I feel like they're just lying
there like we didn't want to buy any
flavoring for this bat so we're making
it's a mystery flavor yeah by which we
mean your girl you're a brainlessly just
a flavor do you want to try my mouth
because it feel like it's lista say you
want you want me to put my licking stick
into your licking hole maybe got cranky
if he does not like candy I hope not we
don't usually celebrate Valentine's Day
you and me but we did something this
year this grey yeah I'm looking forward
to my stomachache
thanks Kona tuna happy Valentine
Valentine's Day if you all are here in
platonic wait how above your wondering
during the poster CL that we had last
weekend we read $71,000 the $7,100 going
to 10 different refugee resettlement
organizations in America thank you all
so much make it all the artist and get
everybody grew up with that together and
everybody can plot something you're
great John I'll see you on Tuesday